hello and welcome everyone
we welcome you to today's webinar cancer
genomics
what we can learn from africa i'm
christy jewell of labyrinths
and i will be moderating today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots
and sponsored by thermo fisher
scientific
for more information on our sponsor
please visit
thermofisher.com now let's get started
i would like to remind everyone that
today's event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box
and click send we will answer as many of
your questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation please
notice you can share today's webinar on
your personal social media
just click on that social sharing tab to
let your friends and colleagues know
about today's live event now if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
just click on that support tab found at
the top right of your presentation
window
or you can use that ask a question box
to let us know you're experiencing a
problem
today's presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
at the end of our presentation click on
the continuing education credits tab
located at the top right of your
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker dr timothy
rebic
vincent l gregory jr professor of cancer
prevention
harvard t.h chan school of public health
and division of population sciences
dana farber cancer institute for a
complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
welcome dr rebbik you may now begin your
presentation
i'd like to thank the presenters for
inviting me today to present about our
work on
developing prostate cancer research
capacity in africa
i'm going to highlight some of the
genetics and
epidemiological studies that we have
formulated
to understand better how cancer
particularly prostate cancer
can be understood better in africa and
i'm going to use the example of the men
of african descent
and carcinoma of the prostate or madcap
network
as a model for how this kind of work can
be done
so why were we studying cancer in africa
just a few notes that the cancer burden
in africa
is anticipated to approximately double
by 2040. the number of deaths for
example will double
we predict that approximately 1.4
million africans
will die of cancer in the year 2040. so
this is a huge
burden in addition we already know that
cancer kills more africans annually than
malaria does
worldwide since about 2015. so while
cancer
is anticipated to rise in incidents and
in death
malaria and other infectious diseases
have dropped
so this presents a huge conundrum to
ministries of health and other policy
makers planning for
disease in africa because they still
have a huge
infectious disease burden yet the
chronic disease burden particularly
cancer
is growing and so we need to now
start addressing our understanding of
cancer and other chronic diseases
so that countries in africa policymakers
ministries of health will be able to
begin to approach this burden
as they face the next 20 years
another issue particularly with genomics
research
is that most genomics research has been
very limited in terms of the racial and
ethnic variation
of the people who have been studied so
here's one piece of data from last year
that bring home the point that the
majority of genomics data that have been
generated
from g was studies has been in european
descent populations with
quite a bit of east asian contribution
but if you look at the purple
bar in the left-hand
piece of this panel very relatively
limited
amount of african data despite the fact
on the
right hand bar africa in purple
makes up a sizable proportion of world
population
so we're really not getting to the point
that we can understand
particularly genomics but also
epidemiological and clinical
features of cancer and other diseases
because we really haven't studied them
very well yet to date
one of the things that i'd like to bring
home to you is that
diverse research data with with respect
to ethnicity and race across
geographies is not only good and helpful
to those populations that are
underrepresented in research
but this kind of data will improve
disease management for all populations
so everybody will benefit
if we can include diverse and
underrepresented populations
this is just one paper of many that
bring home this point so this is a paper
that studied genetic misdiagnosis and
the potential to exacerbate or create
health disparities and what they did in
this paper
is studied um hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy so not cancer but a
disease
uh that has a genetic basis and what
they found
is that in uh in many uh
early studies certain variants
were seen to be very rare in caucasian
populations
and they were inferred to be disease
causative whereas when these were
studied in
black americans they were found to be
fairly common variants
and so what happened is by not studying
the full spectrum of
individuals with respect to race or
ethnicity
mistakes were made in terms of the
inference about whether some
variant was pathogenic or not so again
by studying diverse populations we can
inform genetics for the minority
populations but we can also create
impede the creation and exacerbation
disparities and avoid misdiagnoses
for all populations so there's a lot of
benefit to doing work
that incorporates diverse data and
particularly
because of the high disease burden
in african americans uh that we
should be able to learn more about how
to address and understand
and generate knowledge about african
americans as well
so why study cancer genomics in africa i
sort of alluded to this
we've known a planet of the elder many
hundreds of years ago
told us that africa always brings us
something new
and we know that by studying uh
developing data developing knowledge but
also bringing technology and new tools
uh to a place like africa we can uh
this kind of work can be social and
economic drivers and disruptors we can
leap frog
away from current the current state of
health care and healthcare knowledge
and and and help services
uh sorts of activities uh and disrupt
the current pattern
uh we can foster innovation and
investment in africa we can stem brain
drain because many
uh talented scientists and clinicians
leave africa because the opportunities
aren't there
we can address the unique biological
features and phenotypes of cancer in
africans and african descent populations
and these things are becoming
increasingly feasible due to lower costs
and accessibility so genomic
activities are being done widely across
africa and there's the opportunity to
build these even further
so just with that little bit of
background i'd like to introduce to you
the
concept of a worldwide
consortium that we've developed called
madcap men of african descent and
carcinoma of the prostate
which was set up to link researchers in
the united states and across
africa as you see on this map we have
done that by
receiving nci funding and bringing in
researchers collaborators clinicians
and a variety of different technologists
across
the african diaspora to understand
better prostate cancer which is the
example that i'm going to
illustrate today how we've gone about
doing this
so we received a uo 1 grant a grant from
the nci
and so what i'm going to walk through
now is just to give you a sense of what
it takes
to build this kind of research in africa
where the resources are relatively
limited the capacity is relatively
limited
but it can be done and so i just wanted
to walk through what kinds of things
anyone who is interested
in building research in a low middle
income country might want to think about
and i'll present some data of some of
the things we've done
so in the past five years we you know
had to start up we had to
start from scratch getting human
subjects irbs
forms protocols we needed to pilot our
work to make sure that it could be done
effectively and
accurately in the african setting we had
to accrual
accrue patience that took many years has
been taking many years
during which there's a learning curve
for everyone about how to make these
kinds of things work
and now we're in the reporting phase
meaning we have data
and we're starting to report out some of
the things that we found and i'll give
you a little flavor of that
so what are the kinds of things we need
to think about early on as we develop
this work
the first thing is that in you know if
you're used to doing research in europe
or the united states
you probably have all of the things in
place there are systems there are
processes that are fairly well outlined
to do
the kind of work that we might want in
genetics genomics and cancer
but in africa these things may have to
be developed and much of it is already
in place
but we do need to make sure we have
appropriate systems for the
ethical uh research involving index
irb protocols research consents we have
to think about the regulatory aspects
whether we are in compliance with
government regulations
and have ins proper inter-institutional
agreements
which may or may not have been done
before we have to think about logistical
aspects like supply chain where are the
reagents coming from
how do you get them how do you make sure
that they are there when you need them
we'll have to have sops and protocols
and qa qc met
practices as well as success metrics to
make sure
things are working as we hope and expect
they will
and finally we have fiscal governance
and oversight
compliance issues particularly funding
government funding nih funding is
involved
conflicts of interest and figuring out
appropriate invoicing and payments
so again many of the things that if
you're at a u.s
or european institution you take quite
for granted many of these things have to
be set up
so if you're thinking about doing
research and want to have extramural
funding
building in time and energy in the right
people to create these structures
is critical so as i said we had to
in our startup do a lot of piloting and
we had some great partners in the early
pilots
across our african centers including
people from the broad institute the
center for proteomics and genomics
research
the dana-farber cancer institute and we
have these partnerships build the
piloting and the feasibility for
work in africa we created a number of
uh videos sort of indicated on the right
how to d
extract dna from blood and prepare a dna
stable plate for example so we created
videos we create had
multiple site visits to allow this kind
of work to be done
across all of these centers in a
consistent and
appropriate optimal way so we began to
pilot
these data we in our startup phase where
we would
begin to think about how to accrue
patients
whether we had a pilot phase and we
did evaluations of how well it was
working and then after that pilot phase
had metrics to ensure that what we did
improved the situation
and we we did we we learned that having
a short pilot phase
learning from our mistakes and
correcting those mistakes really made
things work better
uh similarly we had to figure out what
the
data collection protocols were and we
needed to pilot those
so we started collecting data on various
kinds of clinical epidemiological
biospecimen dna kinds of metrics
everything that we needed to do the
research
and we through that pilot generated
final data collection protocols that
worked in all of the african centers
we also needed to figure out how to
sample share
so we had parallel evaluations of the
biosample collection
across all of the centers these were
sent to
the center for proteomic and genomic
research in cape town as well as cider
the center for inherited disease
research
in maryland and they did parallel
evaluation through quantitations
running standard arrays
like the uk biobank axiom array and so
we did these all to understand how we're
doing whether there are things there
that we
needed to improve or learn from so we
did this and we learned through this
pilot phase
how the quality control call rate
worked between the different groups we
did analyses of
race and ethnicity so are we actually
getting
uh these are all african samples are we
getting
uh appropriate discrimination using
ancestry-informative markers to
understand that the people that we think
are south african that we think are west
african in fact
are uh so piloting understanding
who it is we're studying with respect to
ra ethnicity and tribe and
and and background national background
uh was a critical step
in making sure we had uh confidence in
the data that we generated
so let me talk a little bit about some
of the data that we generated just to
give you an example of the kinds of
things we can learn
and the kinds of things that might be
valuable for
improving our knowledge about genomics
and genetics in africa
so one of the things we did is we began
by integrating
gwas data with population genetic data
so we had
a genome-wide association study
associations hits in prostate cancer we
identified 26
prostate cancer gwass hits and we found
161
autosomal snips at these loci so these
are things that were reported
outside these were reported from uh
european and asian populations that were
very clearly
associated with prostate cancer and we
layered upon that some of the data that
we had
from thousand genomes in our data so the
backbone
of uh snips in african populations
and we looked at 68 independent snips
with known risk frequencies and odds
ratios for prostate cancer that were
identified from
other outside gus and we did a number of
different
steps along to understand uh what
the genomic pattern giwas
prostate cancer disease association
pattern looked like
in in and we could make inferences about
uh prostate cancer
in populations around the world so again
we're sort of starting with
basic information about population
genetics and
cancer prostate cancer susceptibility
trying to understand what that might
look like
if we went out of the standard
north american european and asian
populations and tried to make inferences
in
africans so here is one piece of
data that's a little bit hard to see but
there are two panels here
on the left hand side are our 68 snips
the 68 snips that were prostate cancer
susceptibility loci let me just focus on
one of these snips just to help you
focus in rs 758430
a snip that is associated with prostate
cancer on chromosome 2q37
but we don't know what that is there's
not a clear gene there's not a clear
function associated with these
but what the first thing we did using
our population data was to understand
what the impact of this snip was with
respect to risk in african
versus european populations so what you
can see on this left-hand panel those
snips with
we've measured there a genetic
score that allows us to understand the
relative impact of each of these snips
in an african versus a european
population so
those snips that are more likely to have
an impact on risk in africa are in blue
and the snips that are more likely to
have an impact on prostate cancer risk
in europe are in gray
so you can see from these analyses
not all snips are expected to have the
same impact on prostate cancer risk
in all populations and our snip 758430
appears to have a slightly greater
impact on prostate cancer risk in
african populations compared to european
populations
on the right hand side of this slide we
did the same kind of thing but we're
looking at genetic risk scores in
populations
and so the small um lettering that you
see there
is hard to read is uh popular the
different populations
um from african to european to asian
populations so we looked at
west african in the black east african
in the blue
and non-african european and asian in
the gray
and so based on our analyses what you
can see is we predict
that this prostate cancer this set of
pros 68 prostate cancer snips conferring
risk
has a greater impact in west africans a
slightly lower impact on east africans
and a
much less of an impact on non-african
populations so
this suggests that the snips that have
been identified again outside of africa
those snips appear to have some
important impact
that is population or region specific
and this sort of fits with knowledge
that we have
about the risk of prostate cancer which
is a highly genetic disease
in the west versus east african versus
non-african populations
so here's just one piece of data that
was published a little bit ago
this isn't genetic data but it is data
about the prevalence of prostate cancer
across different populations and in this
specific study
they evaluated the prevalence of
prostate cancer in ghana
so though and that's on the right hand
side the prevalence of
prostate cancer in ghanaians is higher
than
in african americans in any of the
published populations in south carolina
michigan or missouri and st
louis and much higher than in u.s
caucasians
so this tells us a couple things so the
epidemiological data about the
prevalence of prostate cancer suggests
west africans or at least canadians have
very high rates of prostate cancer
higher than in african americans that we
usually think of as the highest rate of
prostate cancer in the world
canadians in fact may have even higher
rates and we see from the previous slide
that uh that genetically we would
predict that west africans probably
including ghanaians
are genetically predisposed to having
higher rates of prostate cancer higher
risk of prostate cancer
so we're starting to put together a
picture where the genetic load
for prostate cancer risk is very high in
west africans
we see that the prevalence of prostate
cancer is very high in ghanaians and
west african
so we're starting to put together a
picture to understand better
the burden of genetic risk and of
prostate cancer in
a west african population which is uh
suggesting there's something very
interesting going on there
that will help us understand why
africans and african-americans may have
such high prostate cancer risk
so we continued this line of questioning
and we asked about
selection so this is an evolutionary
genomics question
and what we have on this slide is we
select the selection in
europeans and that's on the y-axis so if
you're higher up on the y-axis you
appear to be under higher selection in
europe versus
on the x-axis if you're further along
the x-axis you are more likely to be
under selection evolutionary selection
at each of these loci in west africa so
each of the blue dots is a snip
one of the million snips that we studied
and cc there's a lot of variations some
are
very high highly selected some are less
highly selected
the black dots are the 68 prostate
cancer snips that we have
and so we see that our snip of interest
rs 758430
is pretty highly selected a very strong
evidence for selection of this snip in
european populations
meaning something happened at this locus
that
happened specifically in europeans
something
occurred in europeans at this particular
locus
which we've already said before is a
prostate cancer locus
so what might that be so what we did is
look drilling down into this locus
7584330
we see that that locus makes it
disproportionately large contribution to
prostate cancer in african-american men
and these um cms scores
um this is metric combined metric of
selection
uh in uh caucasians versus asians
japanese or chinese versus yoruba
in africa have very different patterns
of selection
and so without going into a lot of
detail explaining this pattern of
selection the inference we made
of all of this data that i just showed
you is that our risk allele frequency
is higher in africans and versus
non-africans
so africans actually have a higher
frequency of the alleles
causing prostate cancer but
the reason that this allele is so much
higher in africans is because of
something that happened in europeans
a selection pattern in europeans and
what we learned is that this particular
snip
is adjacent to a gene in linkage
disequilibrium with a gene known as
melanophilin
which is a pigmentation dilution gene so
that's very interesting because we're
looking at a prostate cancer snip
selection in caucasians who obviously
have different
pigmentation lighter pigmentation than
africans
and there's a gene right next to this
prostate cancer sniff that is associated
with pigmentation so we infer that
the haplotype that protects against
prostate cancer
hitchhiked to a very high frequency in
europeans
so here's what that means so on the left
hand side you see there's a pigmentation
maintenance allele
in brown and the prostate cancer risk
allele in orange and so there's a ozone
that has
associated with dark pigmentation and
prostate cancer risk
and there's a second chromosome that's a
pigmentation dilution
which means proposed predisposing to
lighter pigmentation
uh but also on the same chromosome uh a
no a low risk allele
and what we can imagine is that as
individuals
migrated out of africa the pigmentation
selection
for lighter skin led to higher rates of
this protection allele whereas in africa
there are higher rates of pigmentation
led to higher rates of this
risk allele so you can begin to see a
story where we
can begin to take genomic information
and this is an unusual situation because
there's an evolutionary selection going
on
that's also associated with pigmentation
and cancer risk
but you can see how some of this
information can begin to help us
understand
why there might be genetic differences
between european and african populations
that will help us illuminate the causes
of high rates of prostate cancer in
african americans
so in order to take this a step further
we went to uh
take the million and uh so snips that we
had
uh pulled out from the analyses before
and we began to develop
tools that we could use in africa to
better understand
this particular phenomenon so we could
begin to
take a deeper dive into the genomics of
african populations and we created
in combination in collaboration with the
center for proteomics and genomics
research
georgia tech cider and aphametrics at
the time
the madcap africa array which is now
being made publicly available
via thermo-fisher scientific and so
we developed this and i won't go into a
lot of detail on this except to say that
the applied biosystems axiom
genotyping solution from aphametrics
thermofi fisher was the
foundation for what we did using a two
peg design
we enriched the panel for
cancer loci cancer susceptibility loci
particularly prostate cancer but all
cancer susceptibility loci that were
known eqtls that were associated with
prostate cancer
markers the tagged african genome uh
and we ensured that it had overlap with
other arrays that had been developed in
this array
range like enco array or the h3 africa
array so that we would be able
if we use this array to compare it to
some of the other arrays that are out
there
so we ended up with what about 1.5
million snips on two pegs
and again i won't go into all the
details of the new the markers but there
are
a a pretty broad uh spectrum
of these kinds of markers that can be
used
for african ancestry uh studies
gewa studies in africans broadly but
then
with a particular focus on cancer and
cancer-specific loci and eqtls known to
be associated with prostate cancer so
we've
designed this to be widely available for
a lot of purposes
so we also did an evaluation that was
just recently published in cancer
research to evaluate how well this mad
cap array did
and so on this slide you can see uh just
one panel
about the that presents the proportion
of snips captured so an r
squared value and in the brown bars are
the common snips
uh common uh common variants uh and then
the
blue bar is the rare snips and as you
would expect uh we would
hope to tag or we would have designed
this to tag the common snips better than
the rare snips but in fact
we actually are tagging rare snips
pretty well
uh generally above 70 75 percent
uh are squared um and we did this using
about
400 prostate cancer cases from africa
and 400
controls and we see that the african
snips are very accurately computed
particularly the
common snips as we we designed it to be
and the high proportion in all of the
populations that we
uh were interested in as you can see on
the left-hand side
all populations across africa were
tagged
pretty well um so this is a pan-african
panel
that should be good for use in
populations
across the entire continent of africa
i won't go through all of these in in
detail but you can see in panel a here
more about these this panel that we the
mad cap array in blue in panel a
does overlap with the h3 africa and
uncle array panels which allow us again
to combine data to impute
data that across if other panels were
used
we also found in panel b that the madcap
array actually
um
across all populations at a better
frequency
allele frequency lower allele frequency
meaning more fidelity more resolution
than the other panels so we feel that
our our um
array does a little bit better in
tagging uh snips across
all populations than the uncle array or
the h3 africa array
and let me just talk about move to panel
d uh
where we took the three panels and
compared them and we looked at a genome
a genomic region that's associated with
cancer at multiple sites this is
chromosome 8q24
a region strongly associated with
prostate and other cancers and you can
see we did a really good job the mad cap
array being in blue
where you see the peak sort of to the
center left of this
panel d we did a really good job tagging
snips
in this important cancer susceptibility
region
by having a very high density of markers
around cancer regions that were
important
for for cancer so we feel like we did a
pretty good job building
uh the mad cap array and feel like it
will have good use
in a wide variety of cancer and other
disease studies in africa
i just also want to mention that we also
showed
that we can capture good population
structure
and share genetic ancestry among across
africa so we looked just at the
madcap center sites and you can see that
we've um
found that we the we distinguish
populations really well and in fact
we're able to uh identify pretty
accurately
uh deep sub-population differences
across the different uh african sites
you see in panel e
uh we're comparing senegal ghana nigeria
and south africa
and as you can see as we model more and
more populations we're actually able to
make fairly
um refined distinctions between
each of these populations which again is
going to be useful for
understanding um genomic ancestry
in africa but also in african americans
and other african descent populations
uh when we want to study ancestry as
well as disease susceptibility
and finally we looked at a divergence of
polygenic risk scores so we looked at
the genes
the loci at 147 in this case
prostate cancer loci that had been
reported by schumacher at all in 2018
and we created a polygenic risk score
so just a simple uh additive score
of risk across these 147 loci
that was created by schumacher but we
applied it in our population using the
data that i just described to you
and you can see that um the gray uh
curve there is europeans that's the
european
population risk score and that you can
see when we apply the same risk score in
our african populations
that polygenic risk score is shifted to
the right
uh and that suggests to us that even
though this score
was built on european
g loss hits and uh prostate cancer
susceptibility loci
found in europeans so this doesn't
include prostate cancer risk
susceptibility loci that might be
unique to africans or have different
effects in africans that we didn't
detect
earlier you can see there's a shift that
the underlying polygenic
risk score is higher in africans and
this is consistent with what i was
showing you before
that uh african underlying genomic risk
for prostate cancer appears to be higher
than in european and possibly asian
populations
so we're finding some interesting
patterns which are consistent with
african descent individuals having
underlying higher
risk genomic risk for prostate cancer
compared to europeans
and we think we can take this
information a lot further by
and better understand why african
americans and africans
have such high risk of prostate cancer
and begin to explain it by genomic
differences that we identify in these
populations
so let me just end really quickly with a
couple of slides to say what we learned
uh by undertaking all of this work some
of the lessons that we have that are
uh telling us about um the
the what you need to learn what can you
learn by
undertaking these kinds of scientific
activities
uh in a place like africa so first of
all i just want to say there's a lot of
opportunity in africa
there are bright people there are
resources it is possible to do
interesting science
in africa uh and so that's something
that i think everybody should keep in
mind that it's a
a place of opportunity for all kinds of
scientific activities and people should
look at this as an opportunity to do
good science and to do some new
interesting work
uh outside of the the comfort zone of
places
in the u.s or europe so when we did this
we learned that it's really important to
build some
success metrics so we need to you need
to tie the goals of the work to finite
achievable endpoints that have a
realistic timeline
and this is true of course of all
science but you need to tailor this to
the setting that you're working in
and so thinking about what the
appropriate success metrics are
to build this kind of science in africa
specifically is important
and make it realistic and make it
achievable it's really critical to have
institutional buy-in
so you need to have an influential local
pi who cares about the work
and is willing to make sure it happens
we often say it's important to require
co-funding or support by the local
institution
so we need to have some kind of
incentive for the institutions to be on
board to buy in
and that's something that institutions
may or may not have a historic
experience building research capacity
some do
many do but some don't and if they don't
you need to think about how to get the
institution
uh to actually prioritize the ability to
do this kind of work
and they need to then foster an academic
environment conducive to research
so again while many african institutions
have research tracks and research
structures academic structures they're
not always like
we have in the us there may not be a
tenure track there may not be protected
time for researchers
these are things that have to be worked
with
the academic institution to see that
they happen so that research can happen
there has to be governance um there has
to be a requirement that there's in fact
active involvement of stakeholders
including financial and regulatory
personnel
in addition to decision makers this goes
again back to the academic institution
ensuring that there's proper governance
of funding of research activities
you need to leverage existing resources
so based on resources and infrastructure
are often available but they may not be
in one place they may be scattered
around the institution or even around
the city
there may not be a large genomics core
but there may be genomics resources
and you may have to bring them together
supply chain is a major issue
uh supplies are not always easily
available or
they're very expensive or they're um
unreliable so negotiating access to rea
agents and supplies in africa is a
critical feature
to keep the research flowing it's
important to have staffing continuity we
need to guarantee positions for funded
and trained individuals
so again this is an academic requirement
if you have a
researcher who wants to develop a
long-term research career
they need to have a position that will
guarantee continuity over many years and
you can make the same argument for
project managers and lab techs and
things like that
and finally absorptive capacity this
goes back to the success metrics
where are the bottlenecks that are going
to occur
over time how do you find those
bottlenecks so that
the structure can absorb the kind of
work that you're trying to
build and that you can build the
appropriate workforce and
infrastructure not every system can
absorb
all of the work and all of the
infrastructure requirements that may be
needed
so those are things to think about so on
that note i'd just like to thank
a large number of people obviously not
all of whom i can
acknowledge in my uh individually
but this uh clearly this kind of work
involves a team effort
it's been very valuable to have this
team effort bringing people in
from many different institutions around
the world
both to build this capacity but also to
understand how from the local
perspective to do this kind of work and
make it successful
so on that note i'd like to thank you
for inviting me here today
and i would like to open the floor for
the online questions
thank you dr rebic for that informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of our webinar
now to our audience if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
now we have lots of great questions
coming in so let's dive
right in so we can try to get to all of
them
dr rabbik your findings show west
african populations are at
higher risk from prostate cancer
relative to
east african what can you tell us about
admix populations such as
african-american et cetera given
migration patterns
thank you well uh we are very early in
understanding
uh the answer to that question because
we have
previously uh seen in literature some
evidence that uh there's substantial
admixture in african americans
uh and that that admixture may be
associated with
having higher levels of african ancestry
may be associated with higher rate risks
of
prostate cancer but most of the uh tools
that have been used
the panels the arrays that have been
used didn't capture
african ancestry very well so i think
that a lot of the work that's been done
to date in african americans has really
focused around
inferences made by genetic panels
based around european
genetic architecture so i think what
we're going to learn is as we
refine our ability to understand the
african genome better
we'll be able to better understand if
there are gradients
between west east south africa etc
uh and what the impact of those african
contributions are to
disease risk in general and the
admixture that we know happens in has
happened in african americans
with european and native american
populations so
the answer to the question is i think we
have a lot to learn
i think that uh having these african
panels will
teach us a lot more about the african
contribution which i think has been
missing
or at least inadequate in the
thank past dr rebbik though areas
optimized for
african populations you mentioned good
coverage
of other populations as well can you
expand on that
uh if you mean a coverage of
genomes outside of africa
as you know the african genome is
by far the most complex and diverse
of all populations africans were the
ancestral or
origin of all humans and as a result
there's a lot more
uh genetic variability genomic
variability
uh in african populations acros within
and between
african populations than you see in many
other populations around the world
so um you know the amount of genetic
variability in the
north american and native population is
much much smaller than you'd see in
africa
and so uh there's uh a
a need to understand this very rich and
diverse
genomics of uh that's much greater
uh in africa than in other places um and
by doing that we'll be able to better
understand the relationship of these
this very complex genome
with quote-unquote simpler genomes like
you might see
in east asia or in northern europeans
where there's significantly less genomic
variability
so um i think that having a deep
information about all genetic
variability is going to be really very
important
particularly again if you want to
understand african descent individuals
african americans for example
this amount of genetic variability needs
to be
increased or the our understanding of it
i'm not sure if that exactly answers
that question
but
thank you and you know my next question
is two parts
did you see bone marrow bone marrow
failure disorders in africa
genetically inherited or acquired and
did you see cases of
mds aplastic anemia or dba
unfortunately because our study was
really focused around
invasive cancer but particularly
prostate cancer we didn't
record occurrences of any of those
disorders
they do exist but we haven't
systematically studied them so i really
can't comment on their
frequency incidents or the
characteristics of those disorders
dr rebic is there a possibility or a
possible association
with vitamin d and exposure to sunlight
with prostate cancer and africans
given the melanophile in chromosome 2
association yeah i think there's two
things to think about here one is that
the association that we observed was
really kind of a
random thing we didn't expect by
having identified a prostate cancer
that was associated with prostate cancer
itself
we didn't expect to or look for uh the
fact that there was hitchhiking of that
locus
next to a pigmentation gene and so
we haven't really formally studied the
role of melanophilia
on prostate cancer risk and so we don't
know
if that gene that gene the melanophilian
gene has anything to do with prostate
cancer
or which i think is our real hypothesis
here
the selection of melanophilia
in lighter skinned individuals uh was
uh drove the uh and hit the hitchhiking
of this
prostate cancer gene to different levels
of frequency
uh in different populations so i think
the first thing is um
our main hypothesis i believe is that
it was a selection factor related to but
not biologically
causative of prostate cancer
in in european or african populations
but it was the hitchhiking the
evolutionary selection that that drove
the frequency of the prostate cancer
gene not the biology
of melanofilan or pigmentation
necessarily per se
having said that there is evidence that
[Music]
vitamin d exposure might be associated
with prostate cancer risk
and that has been reported from
epidemiological studies
it's not entirely clear whether that's
the case
there is evidence of vitamin d
metabolism
vitamin d receptors and other pathways
related to vitamin d that might be
associated with prostate cancer risk
and of course in africa it's quite
difficult because vitamin d
levels are predicted to be quite low
because of the dark skin pigmentation
uh sun exposure and generation of
vitamin d
through sun exposure in african and
african american individuals
are darkly pigmented individuals is
expected to be quite low
so it's not entirely clear how much that
has to do with the etiology of prostate
cancer
itself but there is also evidence that
prostate cancer might be associated with
vitamin d metabolism so
uh two things to think of you know the
the selection
evolutionary history at the locust that
we studied
the potential that vitamin d might be
linked to prostate cancer but
not a real clear line between a
causative relationship with vitamin d
metabolism
our locus and prostate cancer risk so
lots of work yet to be done to
to understand that relationship
thank you is there a role of
immunohistochemical evaluation
in your research absolutely so the first
line of work that we've described
i just described here is really the
germline inherited
genetic variation but we've also spent a
great deal of time now developing
uh tumor tissue studies uh and
understanding both
by immunohistochemistry as well as
uh gene expression rna
measures of various kinds as well as uh
somatic mutations in tumors so i think
all of this will
help us to understand the relationship
of
biology in prostate carcinogenesis
and how it is perhaps related to more
aggressive disease in african and
african american populations
specific management strategies treatment
strategies that might be different
in these different populations um but i
would
you know emphasize that i don't think we
believe that there are fundamentally
different biologies
uh going on in different races what we
think is that the
manifestation of mutations frequency of
mutations differ
and these result in different patterns
of disease but the biology underlying
uh prostate carcinogenesis is probably
the same for all populations
thank you now dr rebic beside the
genetics
do you think that environmental factors
play a role in the incidence of prostate
cancer
and what do you think those would be so
it's very interesting prostate cancer is
unlike many other common cancers
in that there have been almost no
environmental uh
lifestyle kinds of exposures that have
been associated with prostate cancer
there have been lots of studies lots of
very good studies that have tried to
identify
obesity diet lifestyle
exposures carcinogens that sort of thing
and almost nothing has been identified
consistently as associated with prostate
cancer risk in terms of environments
the main risk factors for prostate
cancer are african descent
african-american race
age family history and
obesity for aggressive prostate cancer
height
is one that's come up but of all
potential environmental factors have
been studied
almost nothing has been aside from the
ones i just mentioned really
consistently been shown to be associated
with prostate cancer so that's very
interesting because you would think
a disease like prostate cancer should
have some
really common environmental causes but
we don't see them
it's not to say there aren't any but we
don't see them and that's very unlike
many of the other common cancers like
lung cancer where you know smoking is
is critical or breast cancer where
reproductive and hormonal factors
uh exposures are important etc
colorectal cancer where diet is really
important
prostate cancer doesn't have any of
those in contrast
the genetic contribution to prostate
cancer susceptibility is the highest of
any of the leading cancers so
prostate cancer is at least very genetic
in its etiology and not very
environmental in its etiology
so a couple of things one is
it is an opportunity for us to
understand and study
africans and prostate cancer
environmental exposures or
environmental exposures that might be
associated with prostate cancer because
this is a very different population with
very different environmental and
lifestyle exposures
maybe studying africa will give us the
opportunity to identify
some of these exposures that we haven't
been able to find in other populations
maybe maybe not but at least it's an
opportunity
but i think that it's very interesting
to
begin to tease apart some of these
factors and understand why prostate
cancer among all major cancers is unique
thank you we have so many great
questions coming in
our next question please tell us whether
it is possible to develop polygenic risk
assessments
for hypertension or heart arrhythmia
absolutely so those
um polygenic risk scores have been
developed for many many disorders not
just cancer but for
uh cardiovascular psycho psychiatric
disorders diabetes
polygenic risk sores have been developed
in many many settings and they are
they they're proving to be useful in uh
combining the information
for lots where lots of different
individual
loci each of which has small effects
can be combined to understand the
underlying genetic
predisposition that an individual may
have and those can be applied in
just about any disease where you can
come up with underlying
snip associations
what was the biggest challenge while
gathering data for the study
from places that are so underrepresented
unrepresented
in research uh you know that there are
many challenges that um are
inherent to working in an uh environment
where
uh resources are limited but i wouldn't
say
you know i i don't actually think of
this as a in terms of the challenges i
have been incredibly impressed by
the hard work and the dedication of our
colleagues in africa they're absolutely
amazing
they work hard and in many cases they
don't get a lot of credit for this
they're not making a lot of money
uh they're not necessarily getting
academic credit
uh because they're i mean they get
academic credit but that's not
necessarily their job description many
of them are clinicians who
need to see patients and yet they're
incredibly dedicated toward
um making this work happen on their
weekends and their evenings and in
in on the side and so while it's a
challenge because a lot of these
uh activities are not in the natural
flow of the hospitals or the
institutions
while there are a lot of challenges with
respect to uh
logistics and governance um you know the
people
and the ability of the people to be
dedicated and to work really hard
and to uh make it happen really
surmounts
all of these these limitations and so i
guess i think in terms of the positives
the people who actually make it happen
uh and not in the negatives which all
can be
um as in our experience overcome
thank you now how is this data inform
clinical trials going forward
um i think that you know clinical trials
in africa are
uh challenging because a lot of the
infrastructure not only the regulatory
infrastructure but the clinical
infrastructure to do example for example
a phase one trial where very intensive
um monitoring and laboratory uh
activities may be required uh but also
access to drugs
um so there's a lot of challenges of
doing this in africa but i think that
the
main thing that i would say the research
contributes to clinical trials is our
understanding
that patients are incredibly diverse uh
the cancers that we're studying in
africans
um look different than the cancers we're
studying in
american white populations european
populations and so
by understanding these underlying
ideological differences as well as the
characteristics the molecular
characteristics of tumors
uh in diverse african populations really
helps us to understand that
developing a clinical trial in a
homogeneous
white population is valuable it's
important obviously but it's
missing a lot of the important knowledge
we may gain from doing a clinical trial
when we exclude more diverse populations
and i don't even just mean african
populations but
uh latinx african-american
asian populations uh that are not as
much part of clinical trials as the
majority populations at least in the
united states
so increasing the diversity our
background knowledge of the diversity
informing um our the need
to address that diversity in uh
clinical research is something that i
think we are
the this kind of research really makes
us aware of and
motivates the need for diverse inclusion
and accrual of clinical trial
participants
dr rebic thank you so much for this q a
session we have time for one
more question but i do want to let our
audience know that we have so many
questions come in that we are unable to
answer
but we want to let you know that these
questions will be answered via the
contact information you provided
at the time of registration so to wrap
dr rebic how long will these cohorts be
followed up in their life
are there defendants to be tested
uh well we hope uh with adequate funding
and
longevity of the investigators to follow
these
uh patients up and follow and pursue the
research in a lot of different
directions
so we have not yet really undertaken
family studies although we're starting
to do that now
we certainly hope to follow up the
patients to uh monitor
uh treatment outcomes and uh mortality
and
and vital status and things like that so
we certainly have
uh short to intermediate uh follow-up uh
interests but we really hope to expand
these studies in a lot of other
directions including
more biologically oriented studies
mechanistically
based studies and interventional studies
particularly in the area of screening
and early detection
one of the problems in africa of course
is very late presentation because of
lack of screening so we're certainly
thinking about
how to implement screening strategies
which in prostate cancer have been very
difficult and very fraught
in the u.s for example but is a great
need in africa so i think that the
direction that we're taking these is
really toward
using the basic uh epidemiological and
causation knowledge we're getting to
prevent early detect
cancers and reduce mortality as a result
thank you and dr rabbit can you i want
to squeeze one more question in because
this question has come in a few times
is there an application process for the
new centers that would like to join this
initiative
uh well email me there's a we have a
website
uh www.madcapnetwork.org
on that website is a lot of information
about sim our
studies we also have a link below with
an email address that people can contact
us we're very happy to have uh
collaborators join both as
contributors to the science but also as
our data become available
they will be made public they will be
shareable through a process that we have
the genomic data are all being deposited
uh
on a uh you know in a public space so
that people will have access to the data
so there are a lot of opportunities both
to collaborate and in the future to use
our data uh for
other uh studies uh in a lot of
different directions so we
absolutely welcome uh collaboration and
have people
visit our website and learn more and
contact us
dr rebbik thank you so much for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank robert and
our sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
now before we go i do want to thank our
audience again for joining us and for
their interesting questions
we had a numerous amount of questions
that we weren't able to answer and again
those will be answered via the email
address you provided
at the time of registration today's
webcast
can be viewed on demand and lab routes
will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now we thank you for
joining us
and we hope to see you again soon have a
great day